[Music]
it's been fantastic this year the event
is so huge awesome I am very excited to
learn more about disruption detector
from you today so this is a demo I came
up with in December issue of this year
and the goal was to take people and let
them break things and then see in real
time how are monitoring and logging and
error reporting system showed that so
that they had a better idea of what it
would look like if they used it for
their own applications because we do all
these demos but the whole goal most of
the demos is that everything stays up
all the time so you don't get to see
what those bad days on the Internet look
like and so I wanted to give folks the
opportunity to do that so what we've got
going on here is we've actually got a
whole bunch of different ways you can
break stuff the panel behind you has a
bunch of different conservation of the
errors that you can send panel behind me
since traffic and further down we have
panels that kill load balancers and kill
VMs and all of that is acting against a
kubernetes application that I'm running
in the background that we're trying to
keep up well every one of the conference
here tries to take it down it's been
fantastic and then once you're done with
all of that you get to see up at the top
how those things look in stackdriver in
real time excellent and I know you
mentioned a number of products on Google
cloud platform as well as kubernetes can
you talk a little bit about the
technology that went into building
disruption detector so it wasn't winton
but we've actually managed to use every
single one of google clouds compute
options in this product or in this demo
we have cloud functions backing both the
errors of the load we have kubernetes
obviously is the app that we're running
I am using compute engine to run a cron
job that puts everything back together
after the attendees break it and I'm
using App Engine as a test harness so
that I could build this independently of
the manufacturing in the demo and that's
also gonna potentially let us take this
demo to events where we don't have this
much space and we can do it as a
web-based app and what makes this
interesting and useful and helpful to
our developers so as much as we don't
want it to happen stuff always goes
wrong I was talking yesterday in my talk
that even if
you write the best code ever and your
infrastructure is perfect you could
always have a day when a shark bites
through the undersea fiber cable because
that's actually happened and so what
this teaches you and teaches developers
is that if they use google cloud
spectrum our offering we have a bunch of
different products that all play well
together it can give you an overview of
your system so you can quickly figure
out what's wrong and then fix it and
it's really really interesting for folks
because in the past people have been
putting these technologies together from
a variety of different vendors but if
they use stock driver on GCP they all
come we have all the options already
here excellent well thank you very much
for the tour and I hope you enjoy the
last day of the conference
[Music]